it's so similar to other small towns
around the country and little
differences that we're here on Maui and
in the Pacific now this town is very
special to me you know after being in
the big cities around the world nothing
like coming home to my little town
so this is the ballroom going into this
room is like walking through time these
are Japanese floats to find these is
incredibly rare and incredibly lucky if
you look up at the board's over here I
can go exactly through each one of these
and tell you how you know special they
all are and how they were you know the
top-of-the-line latest and greatest in
that particular time period I can look
over these boards and really realize you
know things evolve and how things are
gonna continue to evolve
this is my favorite part about just
driving on the North Shore is you see
the ocean you can see what the
conditions are doing and it gives you so
amped when you come around this little
bend here because then you see the most
popular winter and kitesurf place you
know this is basically the mecca of wind
swartzes help keep up this is where
champions have been made this is where
big waves have been ridden and this is
where a lot of fun goes down every day
can't even tell that this display is you
know harbors and creates the biggest
surf in the world has known my future in
my mind is to you know continue to grow
as an athlete and as a person I want to
be able to you know be pushing the
limits of my sports to the next level
but at the same time as well I want to
be able to bring you know the other side
of things which is off the water you
know be able to you know wear a suit and
have this amazing style and you know be
able to kind of like these boards
continue to evolve throughout time I
mean I could compare that to this board
right here which was shaped by legendary
shaper my former shaper Herald eggie
coming to this board right here which is
the oldest board that we do have here
this is out of the 1930s and it was made
of wood you know when you walk into this
room and look at this board that this is
definitely the oldest one just like
you're you know you're a product of
where you're from you're also a product
the people you hang around and the
people you are with and so I'd say the
person I am now is directly correlated
to the people I'm around which is
family my friends and all these amazing
people we've had so many different
boards kind of come through this room
the ones that are the most special end
up sticking all the wars I have now who
knows they may be hanging up in this
room as well and I might go in here and
look at them and just think to myself
how did I even ride that thing and
that's exciting stuff because that just
means the future is bright and the
future is exciting and if we think we're
doing incredible things now what's it
gonna be like in 20 years
if you want to see me do more cool stuff
check out me windsurfing kitesurfing
soon on the channel